- [Instructor] So right
over here, I have a flower
and I have a ruler
and what I wanna do is figure
out how wide this flower is.
So you can pause the video
and think about how I would do that.
All right, now let's do this together.
So if I wanna figure out
how wide the flower is,
first I could say, all right,
the left side of the
flower goes about this far.
So let me draw a line here just
so we can really keep track
of how far we go to the left
and then the right side of the
flower goes about that far.
So let's keep track of that
and then we can use our
ruler to measure the distance
between those two lines.
We can rotate it a little bit
then I'm going to move it a little bit
and I want the left edge of the ruler
to start at that left line.
So starting right over
here and then we could see
that it's one, two, three inches roughly
to get us to the right side.
So it looks like this
flower right over here
is three inches wide.